Hello Freak bitches.
Yeah,
I've had people get upset at me about um,
talking about,
uh,
upcoming martial arts fights because a,
I don't give predictions.
I very,
very,
very rarely give predictions unless there's some gross mismatch.
It really shouldn't be happening in the first place because you really have no
idea what's going to happen and there's a high likelihood that something might
happen.
If I look at the way one guy moves versus another guy moves and I go into my
database of experiences of seeing a lot of live competition and knowing what one
person is capable of,
I can make,
I can make a statement with reasonable certainty but I don't know if they were
injured in training.
I don't know if they come into the fight sick.
I don't know if they're breaking up with their girlfriend.
I don't know if they got staph infection two weeks before the fight and run
ended up biotics.
There's so many variables.
I don't know if they might get headbutted like we talked about earlier or they
might have an injury like in the middle of the fight,
like something goes wrong and their knee blows out.
There's so many variables.
Has the thing between the boxer and the MMA guy happened to get the thing?
See,
this is,
I love when someone is consoles.
I know.
I love that though.
No,
I'm not.
I'm not criticizing you.
But I love when someone is so far removed,
but there's still aware of something that's like a big cultural event.
No,
it takes place August 26 I think even,
I'm an unbelievable novice when it comes to this stuff.
I think I could make a prediction here in front of your huge podcast that the
MMA guy is going to get trashed.
Correct.
Um,
I would imagine that most likely he is going to lose a boxing match to the best
boxer that has ever lost this fight.
Just for,
for my name thing,
if you wanted to see a figure skater play hockey against Wayne Gretzky.
Okay.
So why would the MMA guy put himself up for that potential humiliation,
money,
dollar,
dollar bills?
Y'All been on your show?
No,
he has not.
I fucked up.
I should have had him on back before he blew up.
He's too big now.
I referred to him as a Conrad last time or something.
Right.
Something like that.
His name is Connor.
Connor Mcgregor.
Yeah.
Um,
I,
uh,
it's,
he's a,
a real meteoric,
uh,
entity and like the most media or can all of combat sports.
He became so famous so quick and for cause he's a,
he's a real unicorn in a lot of ways.
It's got so many different things going for him.
Handsome guy,
brutal knockout artists,
predicts outcomes and pulls them off.
And uh,
it has been incredibly successful in a short period of time.
One,
two world titles in two different weight classes and is arguably the greatest
trash-talker ever.
He trashed talks better than anybody.
Is that right?
There is actually a big thing that's going on today,
right?
The press conference,
actually I'm reading the thing that scalping tickets outside of it for 40 bucks
right now to 40.
It's a free,
it was free.
Oh,
my nephew is probably all over that stuff,
right?
Probably.
Yeah.
It's,
um,
it's,
it's the press conference itself will be a show because this guy is so good at
getting people riled up and talking shit.
And that's half the fun.
Like,
I was too young to appreciate the Muhammad Ali days,
but I would imagine that like when Muhammad Ali was challenging Sonny Liston,
like half of the fun was Mohammed Ali talking shit.
Like,
this guy's crazy.
okay.